Here are the seven rules of free speech in
schools.
One: Students from first grade to 12 can't
be punished based on their political or religious speech
as the Supreme Court said in the Tinker case:
'It can hardly be argued that students shed their constitutional rights at the schoolhouse gate.'
This protects, for instance, wearing black
arm bands to protest a war,
distributing religious messages to classmates
between classes,
or criticizing the teacher over lunch.
Two: Schools can punish speech that materially
disrupts school work,
for instance, because it prompts fights.
That's why lower courts have let schools ban
clothing that displays confederate flags
and in one case even clothing that displays
an American flag on Cinco de Mayo
when that display lead to violence.
That's a kind of heckler's veto, where threats
against the speaker
are used by the government to justify restricting
the speaker
rather than the threaders.
Usually the government can't impose such a
heckler's veto
but the rule in schools seems to be different.
That may not seem right to you but I don't make
the law, I just make videos about it.
Schools can also punish students for using
vulgarities or sexual innuendo.
So if you do criticize that teacher over lunch,
be, you know, polite about it.
Four: Schools can punish speech that seems
to praise drug use
and probably also alcohol use and other crimes
at least when that speech doesn't seem political.
That's from Morse v. Frederick where the Supreme
Court said a school could suspend a student
for holding up a banner that read 'Bong Hits
4 Jesus.'
Yes, this is a real case.
In fact you can actually find audio
of Supreme Court Justice Stephen Breyer saying
'Bong Hits 4 Jesus.'
Which is completely surreal.
So, 'legalize marijuana' is probably okay
but 'marijuana is awesome' probably isn't.
Five: You may have the right to speak at school
but you don't have the right to speak in the
school newspaper.
Courts see the newspaper as the school's own
speech
even if the students are the ones who wrote
it.
The principal has ultimate control over what
goes in the newspaper
and can delete or edit any article for pretty
much any reason.
Six: Everything said so far deals with public
schools.
Under the so-called state action doctrine,
the First Amendment doesn't limit private
schools.
Even ones that get tax breaks or government
funds.
The first words of the first amendment are
'Congress shall make no law'
that applies to the federal government.
The Fourteenth Amendment basically says no
state shall violate people's rights.
That applies the First Amendment to state
and local governments.
But the Constitution generally doesn't constrain
private property owners,
private landlords, private schools or anyone
else.
That's why when your parents told you to stop
saying rude things at the dinner table
and you asked 'what about my First Amendment
rights.'
They said 'let's talk about the state action
doctrine.'
Or at least that's what they should have said.
Seven: It's all different in California.
Sure everything is different in California,
but what I mean is that everything so far is the
constitutional minimum that all states must provide.
Some states have passed laws that provide
more protections to students.
In California, for instance, high school students
generally can't be punished for their speech
even if it provokes other students into acting
disruptively.
They generally can't be punished for speech
about drugs or alcohol or even vulgar speech.
And public school newspapers are mostly free
from being censored by the administration.
Student newspapers are protected in some other
states too.
Indeed, in California, all the student speech
protections,
but not the student newspaper speech protections,
apply to private high school students as well.
But not in religious high schools.
So, there you have it.
Political and religious speech is protected,
but not disruptive speech, vulgar speech,
or speech praising drugs.
Also official school newspapers are the school's
own speech,
this stuff really only applies to public schools
and of course, California is different.
That's the law of free speech in school,
cobbled together by the court and a few legislatures
over the past 50 years or so.
This is not legal advice,
if this were legal advice, it would be followed
by a bill.
Please use responsibly.
Written by Eugene Volokh,
who is an actual real life First Amendment
Law Professor at UCLA.
I'm Eugene Volokh and I approve this message.